Today we're going to discuss whether consideration can be sufficient,
even if it loses its value following contract formation.
We'll explore this question by looking at app fell versus Prudential Bache
securities.
A case decided by New York state's highest court in 1993 the plaintiffs and
investment banker and lawyer approached an investment bank,
the predecessor to Prudential Bache securities,
and they approach the bank with an idea for a new way of issuing municipal bonds
at the time,
issuing stock or bonds involved issuing paper certificates.
The plaintiff's proposed a new system that allowed the municipal bonds to trade
paperlessly through electronic book entries.
After reviewing a lengthy detailed summary of the techniques involved in the
plaintiff's proposal,
and after several weeks of negotiation,
the defendant bank entered into a contract with the plaintiffs.
The contract provided that the plaintiffs conveyed their rights to the
techniques in return for a stipulated payment rate from the defendant for its
use of the techniques for a period from October,
1982 to January,
1988 for at least the first year of the contract,
the defendant company was the only underwriter and the industry using the
paperless system by 1985 by which time many other investment banks were using
similar computerized models.
The defendant companies stopped making payments.
The company alleged that the idea is app fell,
can be conveyed in his proposal,
had been in the public domain at the time of the sale agreement and argued that
in order to constitute consideration for the party's agreement,
App Hill's idea had to be but was not novel.
The trial court found for the plaintiff,
the appellate division,
reversed agreeing with the defendant that an idea had to be novel to constitute
consideration and that novelty was a fact to be determined at trial.
But the incident court reversed determining that an idea need not be novel to
constitute valid consideration.
Let's walk through the Court of Appeals Holding.
The court emphasized first that the parties to a contract are free to make their
bargain even if the consideration exchanged is grossly unequal or of dubious
value.
It's enough that something of real value in the eyes of the law was exchanged.
It rejected the defendants and the appellate division's belief that novelty was
required for contracts involving the of ideas explaining that the case is on
which the defendant and lower court relied for for their contention only used
novelty as a way to ascertain the value of an idea.
Value at the time of contract formation was the crucial concern.
So long as the idea offered as consideration had value to the defendant at the
time of contract formation.
The idea was valid consideration.
Further,
the court pointed out that even if the idea itself wasn't novel,
it was novel to the defendant and indication that the idea had value to the
company.
The court also explained other reasons why the idea was quote manifestly unquote
of value to potential bache securities.
The company used APP fells proposed computerized book entry system for several
years.
It did so an advance of its competitors and through its confidentiality
agreement precluded the disclosure of the ideas to its competitors.
A clear articulation of the relationship between novelty and value may be found
in one of the cases on upon which the defendant relied downy versus General Food
Corporation and opinion.
The court of Appeals of New York at issued in 1972 in that case,
the plaintiff submitted to an employee of general foods and idea to market Jello
using a mister wiggle.
The company rejected this marketing idea,
but several months later other employees apparently unaware of Downey suggestion
also came up with the idea of Mr. Wiggle and market it when the plaintiff sued
General Food Corporation showed evidence that that proposed a TV commercial
years earlier involving variations of wiggle and the court of Appeals ruled in
the company's favor.
The point was simply that if general foods already was aware of the wiggle
notion when Downey proposed it to them,
Downey's disclosure had no value to general foods and so could not constitute
valid consideration in this case.
By contrast,
Prudential Bache securities,
fully conceited,
it did not have knowledge of any similar electronic book entry proposal before
hearing it from the plaintiff.
Notably lacking in this opinion are any dollar figures.
We do not know what prudential based securities paid for the plaintiffs
proposal.
What if prudential paid for the use of the idea?
Primarily because they believed it was a novel one and paid much more than it
otherwise would have been willing to pay,
assuming it would have more than a couple of years a headstart on its
competitors in the paperless securities trading.
With that in mind,
do you see any problems with the court's determination that the idea was
obviously a value to the defendant?
So is the consideration doctrine concerned with the equivalents of exchange?
That is whether there are disparities in the value of what the parties promise
each other.
No.
The consideration doctrine does not police the equivalents of exchange.
Even very large disparities in the respective parties consideration typically
will not give rise to an unenforceable contract because of this,
uh,
consideration doctrine is a very poor policy instrument to assure substantive
fairness.
On the other hand,
what if the plaintiffs in this case had represented that the idea was in fact
novel or if both parties wrongly believed this was so should the court have
heard and implicit representation from the plaintiff that the idea was novel or
is the default of non,
uh,
novelty preferable?
We will discuss cases involving misrepresentation or,
uh,
a mistaken inferences of fact later on in the course.
Yeah.
So what have we learned from this case?
We know that ideas do not have to be novel to constitute consideration,
but more broadly and more importantly,
decision suggests that consideration should be judged at the time of
contracting,
even if a party's consideration after formation ceases to have value as here.
Because midway through the term of the contract,
the defendant,
the defendant's competitors,
were using similar electronic book entry systems,
the consideration remains adequate because at the time of contracting it had
value.
It's what motivated the banks promise.
Finally,
we emphasize again that the consideration doctrine generally does not inquire
into how equal the consideration of the parties is.